(perky synth music)
- Good afternoon, I'm William Lester,
professor of chemistry
and chair of the Hitchcock
Professorship Committee.
On behalf of the Hitchcock Professorship,
we're pleased to welcome Sir John Gurdon
as this year's speaker in the Charles M.
and Martha Hitchcock Lecture Series.
So John Gurdon's groundbreaking studies
in nuclear transplantation
galvanized effort
to clone a mammal from an adult cell,
a quest that in 1996 produced
a healthy sheep named Dolly.
The intellectual driving
force behind this success
was Gurdon's discovery
that cells of the body
are capable of differentiating
into all cell types
of the vertebrate animal.
Gurdon provided unprecedented evidence
that nuclear transplantations
from specialized cells
could give rise to adult, fertile
genetic copies of their donor.
His findings also yielded wide-ranging
medical implications for the use
of stem cells in tissue therapy.
Gurdon recently revisited this field
to study nuclear
reprogramming and cell fate
determination in amphibians.
Gurdon was born on October 2nd, 1933,
in Dippenhall, England, and
entered Christ Church College
at Oxford University
intending to study Classics.
He transferred to the
Department of Zoology,
earning his PhD in embryology in 1960.
Following postdoctoral
work at the California
Institute of Technology,
and a six-month sabbatical
at the Carnegie Institution in Baltimore,
in 1965 Gurdon returned
to Oxford University.
In 1971 he moved to the
Medical Research Council's
laboratory of molecular
biology in Cambridge,
subsequently becoming head
of the Cell Biology Division.
He was appointed professor of cell biology
in the University of Cambridge in 1983,
and served as master of
Magdalene College Cambridge
from 1995 to 2002.
Gurdon is an active researcher
at the Wellcome Trust
Cancer Research UK Gurdon
Institute of Cancer
and Developmental Biology,
and served as its first
chairman from 1988 to 2001.
Sir John Gurdon's
international awards and honors
include the Albert Bechet Prize
of the Belgian Royal Academy
in 1968; the Royal Medal in
1985; and the Copley Medal
in 2003 of the Royal Society of London;
International Prize for
Biology from Japan, 1987;
the Wolf Prize in Medicine,
1989; and the Conklin Medal
of the Society for
Developmental Biology in 2001.
He is a fellow of the Royal
Society and a foreign member
of numerous academies including
the Academia Europaea;
American Philosophical
Society; United States National
Academy of Sciences,
Institute of Medicine;
Académie des Sciences, Institut de France.
Please join me in
welcoming Sir John Gurdon.
(applause)
- So, thank you, indeed, Dean
Mason and Professor Lester
for this most welcome invitation
to give these two talks.
I'm told that one of my
predecessors was someone called
Joseph Needham, and he was a great expert
on Chinese history, and
particularly on Chinese painting,
which in historic times was mostly done
with a paintbrush,
including their writing.
Joseph Needham enjoyed the reputation
of a very focused approach to his subjects
and he was well known
to have offered a course
of five one-hour lectures entitled,
The History of the Brush.
Now that's a more focused
approach than I planned
to take today and tomorrow,
when I would like to talk
about the, here we are.
No, we're not; this is, oh, there.
Thank heavens, yes,
I'm so nervous of these
computer things they may not work.
So I'm going to talk
today about the process
by which an egg makes an early
embryo and a later embryo,
and finally an adult, and
in the case of mammals,
it's possible to take
these early embryo cells,
place them in culture, and they're called
embryonic stem cells, implant
them back into an embryo,
and then grow eventually
an adult, and so one goes
from an egg, a fertilized
egg, through the early
developmental stages
so that you end up with
a range of specialized cells,
such as blood, and skin,
and these other things
of which we consist.
Now there are three
approaches that are often used
in this kind of work, which
are aimed at telling us
how early in development
cells actually take decisions.
When do the early embryonic cells decide
what they going to become in development?
And these three approaches
are essentially the following.
One is to take the
early embryo and to mark
a few of those cells and
simply follow them through
and ask what they've become.
This is called lineage studies,
and if you mark cells in
that part of an embryo
they will become the backbone, sometimes
called notochord, of the embryo.
That's really just to tell
you what the normal history
of these early cells is.
And then the second approach
is often called specification,
where you mark the same
cells, but then you take them
out of the rest of the embryo,
and grow them in culture,
and ask what they've become.
In many cases, these cells
already know what they're
going to become, and so
they will become backbone,
often called notochord,
in spite of the fact
that they have been
taken out of the embryo
and receive no information
from the cells around them.
And then the third approach
is called determination,
where you again mark
these cells at that part
of the embryo, but you
then transplant them
into another part of another
embryo, a different part,
and if these cells really
know what they're going to be,
if they've made up their mind
to follow a particular fate,
you will find that these
cells again become backbone
in a secondary embryo already
formed on top of the first.
Those are the basic procedures
by which one can follow
the early decisions that cells take.
And one of the lessons
I'm going to talk about is
the fact that cells take
a very early decision,
even a few hours after they're formed
as to what they're going to become.
They're very committed
to their future career.
Now, one can demonstrate
this rather easily
by putting a little
mark on a fertilized egg
at one particular point,
actually the point
just below where a sperm
enters, and when you grow
those eggs into, in this case, tadpoles,
you can barely see it here,
but there is a blue mark
just under the tail on
each of these larvae.
It shows that that
particular bit of the egg
already knows just as a one-cell stage
what it should become in the rest of life.
This is called the lineage analysis.
One can actually, interestingly,
follow lineage analysis
of scientists, and when
you do this you find that
there's a famous early
scientist called Boveri
of whom a student was Spemann,
one of the most famous
embryologists there are.
Of him, a student was Baltzer.
This is now in Switzerland,
of whom there was
a student called Hadorn,
well known to Drosophila
embryologists, and so
you go down until you get
to Professor Richard
Harland, who is my host.
Now, whether he knows or not that he was
a great, great, great,
great scientific grandchild
of Boveri I'm not quite sure,
but it's an interesting fact
that a large number,
perhaps even nearly all,
of the European people
in this field trace back
to one individual, in this case, Boveri.
So that exemplifies the
principle of lineage.
Now what I'm going to do
in this talk is to try
and cover four points, be
talking a little bit about
the pre-fertilization
control of development.
Interestingly, an awful lot
of what happens as we form
from an egg takes place
even before fertilization.
I shall then talk a bit
about what we call asymmetric
cell division, and that's
one of the two fundamental
mechanisms by which different
kinds of cells are formed.
The other of these two
mechanisms is called signaling
between cells, and I shall
talk about that later.
And then finally something about the
so-called community effect.
So that's what I want to talk about.
And to start off with in
talking about pre-fertilization
control of development,
and that really has to do
with what information exists
in the egg and the sperm
before they actually meet each other.
Now this topic was of interest to people
a long time ago, and I'm quoting here
from Hartsoeker, 1694,
and as a matter of fact,
Joseph Needham, to whom I've
referred was a well-known
historian of embryology.
He shows this picture of
what was seen at the time
to be a clear view of the sperm,
and if you look carefully
you can see more or less
a complete adult with
the arms neatly folded
'round the legs of this
individual, which was imagined
to be present in the sperm.
And they thought that's
how people actually arose.
Now that's no longer believed
to be the case once we had
better microscopes, so things
have moved on from then.
But I do want to talk about
a very early experiment
which is largely overlooked
at the present time,
and this has to do with snails.
Now this diagram looks
complicated, but actually
it's not actually complicated at all.
And it relates to the fact
that snails come with a coil.
And you can call them right-handed snails
or left-handed snails, depending which,
when you look down from
the top, the spiral
goes one way or another.
Now back in the 1920s, people
began investigating this
and they found a rather curious effect,
that if you cross, this
is a left-handed snail,
you can barely read the
writing, I'm afraid.
That is a right-handed
snail; you see they coil
different ways.
When you do that all of the offspring
actually become left-handed snails,
and when you cross the
two left-handed snails,
all of their offspring
become right-handed snails,
a very complicated situation.
But it managed to be interpreted
at that time correctly,
that all that really
matters is the genetic
composition of the mother.
So in this case, they call it a small dd
meaning a sinistral, and when
the mother is of that kind,
all her offspring will
have the left-handed coil
irrespective of what the
snail's husband might have been.
And likewise, in this
case, you have this snail
which has a genetic constitution
of a right-handedness,
and all their offspring
will be right-handed snails.
And this was worked out
at that time in 1920,
and it was the very first
example where it was shown
that the mother's constitution
actually determines
the major characteristics
of all her offspring,
so there's a maternal
inheritance in this hand,
in this case, of the
handedness of the individual.
The whole symmetry is changed 'round.
Rather a remarkable case.
Now I quote that for a couple of reasons,
and I rather like the original paper
where you couldn't do this nowadays.
They show a picture of the South Yorkshire
Malacological Society on a Sunday outing
at King Lane Pond, Leeds,
where it so happened
that these left-handed snails
were extremely abundant.
They're actually otherwise very rare,
so this was obviously not
a well-subscribed society
where there's as far as I
can see about 10 members
neatly spaced 'round this
small puddle outside Yorkshire.
It's nice that in those days
you could publish a picture
of that kind of thing in
the middle of your paper.
The other thing that's
particularly interesting
about this particular work
is that one of the people
who did it was a man called Captain Diver,
Captain because he was an army man,
and he had a career in
the Parliamentary Service,
so he worked for six months of the year
as an administrator in Parliament
in the government circles,
and for the other six
months, he grew snails
in his private house in jam jars.
And he actually did the key experiments
working out how this all happened.
And he actually was an
amateur; he was not trained
as a scientist, and it's
therefore interesting that
one of the fundamental discoveries about
maternal inheritance was actually achieved
by an amateur who had no
scientific training at all.
And it makes the point
that there is, in fact,
a role for amateur scientists.
Now, I'm now going to
turn to the second point,
part of my talk, and this is the process
called asymmetric cell division.
We know that people, animals,
including ourselves, have three axes.
There's the anterior-posterior axis,
and this is largely
determined by your mother,
mother's composition.
The second axis is the dorsoventral axis,
the back, the front; that,
as we'll see, is largely
determined most cases by
an environmental influence
such as where the sperm enters.
The third axis, the difference
between left and right,
is particularly interesting, but actually
we do not still understand the mechanism
of how a completely
bilaterally symmetrical cell
can somehow consistently
form two equal cells,
mirror images of each other,
and yet one will always
be the left-handed side
and the other the right.
Why is the heart on the left?
We don't actually
understand that even now.
But we do know this principle,
and that's illustrated
here by looking at cells.
Here's a cell, and it makes some products
which are shown as the
red spots, and usually
these cells have something on one side
like another cell or
membrane, and as a result,
these products go to one side of the cell,
the one distal from that substrate.
And when the cell divides,
most of these products
go into one daughter cell, not the other.
So it's an asymmetric
division, and the one
that gets most of them will then follow
a differentiated fate,
for example, becoming
a nerve cell, and the other
one remains as a stem cell,
and later on will divide again to make
another kind of asymmetric division,
that being one important
example of this process.
Now the other person who
contributed a great deal
to this was Conklin; his
early work was actually
about 1905, and he worked
with a marine organism
called Styela, and he established
the important principle
that this egg has, as
it happens, a little bit
of yellow pigment, which
when you follow it through,
always ends up in the
tail muscle of the larva.
So it's a yellow cytoplasm correlates
with tail muscle determination.
And that was an important
principle established
some hundred years ago
by careful observation,
and again illustrates
this important principle
that something is localized
in the very earliest stages
of development which commits
the embryo or organism
to follow a certain kind of fate.
Then there are the eggs of amphibians
which happen to be conveniently colored,
black on the top and white underneath.
And a really important work
by one of your colleagues,
John Gerhart, established some years ago
that the fundamental
principle here was that
there is a polarity in one direction.
And this is set up maternally.
And the sperm generally enters at one side
and opposite it, it
forms a special structure
which this is called a Nieuwkoop center
after one of the famous embryologists,
and there's a rotation and at this point,
the cells start entering the embryo
and they make the main axis.
So this illustrates the
fundamental principle
that you have a maternal
polarity on top of which
there is an environmental
polarity, which is
at right angles to it, so you
establish the first two axes.
Now mammals like ourselves
are often thought
to be a different principle.
This is a mammal egg and
they're difficult to work with
because they're extremely small.
You may not know that the egg of a mouse,
a human, and an elephant are
all exactly the same size,
about 70 microns across,
and it has been thought
for a long time that these
eggs have no preformed
maternal polarity because
you actually can't see any.
They look completely even.
But in fact, there are
experiments by my colleague
Magdalena Zernicka-Goetz, who has done
some remarkable
experiments with these eggs
where you divide out the
cells and you collect the ones
that are in a certain position in relation
to the result of fertilization,
and the main point
is the green, blue, and red
embryos derived from this
follow completely different fates.
But I show this for another reason
because the manipulations
involved in this process
are actually quite striking,
and we're going to see
how you have to do these things.
In this case, this is a
very fine micropipette,
which is going to pick
up a fluorescent bead
and attach it to one point on the embryo.
And this is actually mouse
egg, but it would look
exactly the same if it was a human egg.
This is a pipette which
will pull that cell
away from the rest of the embryo.
You see it being dragged away
and a massive distortion,
but amazingly, the embryos survive.
This one is actually taking a cell away
from the rest of the
embryo and you can now see
they focus and prepare to
pull another cell away.
That's one of the
manipulations which can be done
and could just as well be done with humans
and indeed, that is the process used
when you take a cell from
a human embryo, one cell,
and test it for, say, a genetic disease.
If you're looking for
cystic fibrosis patients,
that's a very good way
of identifying them.
And amazingly, you can pull off one cell
from the very early
stages, when there are only
about eight, and the rest
of the embryo survives.
Now what we have not
been able to see so far
is the other video.
Yes, this may do it.
This is the one I meant to show first.
The pipette pushes right into that egg.
It's amazing how it can
tolerate this huge deformation.
It's then going to pick up
a fluorescent bead, and now
you can begin to see these
beads waiting around there.
And in a moment the pipette,
which is extremely small,
will come along and will pick up
one of these beads on the tip.
There you see it now; then it will push
this again right inside that egg.
It's amazing what these
eggs will tolerate.
There it goes right inside,
about to go right inside,
dig in, completely distort it and leaves
the bead on the outside.
And we'll see in a moment that that is,
since it's marked fluorescently
you will suddenly see
this brightly colored fluorescent bead
sitting on the outside
which enables you to mark
one particular part of that embryo
and heads to follow its fate.
So these are the kinds of things which
amazingly can be done, I
think with these small eggs,
extraordinarily tolerant to manipulation.
Now the last example
of asymmetric divisions
is this one with a colleague Andrea Brand
who works with the future nerve cells.
The red is the nucleus and the green,
you can see, is a determinant.
It's molecules which actually
tell the daughter cells
what to become, and in
the video, a brief video
we'll see in a moment,
you'll see that the green
is all segregated to one
of the two daughter cells.
It all goes to one side.
Now if you watch quickly the
green has all gone to that side
and it gets into that
cell, it's very short,
not the other one.
So this is a living image of the movement,
the partitioning of that material into one
of the two daughter
cells which then tells it
what it should become.
So the conclusion from
that part of the talk
is simply to say that one of
the fundamental mechanisms
of how we start life as eggs
and turn into individuals
is this idea that cells, a parental cell,
puts its key molecules into
one of the two daughter cells
and that then tells that daughter cell
what fate it should become.
In this case it distinguishes a nerve cell
from the parental stem cell.
So now the third part of the talk concerns
signaling between cells, and this is
the second fundamental mechanism by which
different kinds of cells are formed.
And the simplest possible
form of this process
is called a simple threshold signaling.
Cells have to be close
together, and the whole process
is independent of time and concentration.
And the principle is this:
that you have a so-called
responding cell and another
cell that sends out signals,
and this cell comes adjacent to that one,
sends signals to this
cell, which now follows
a new cell fate, and it does that because
it receives signals, signal molecules,
some of which we know, from a nearby cell.
A rather simple process,
and it doesn't really matter
how much information it gets,
as long as it gets enough
that exceeds the threshold,
it will follow this new fate.
So that's the simple form of signaling.
But there are more complex forms.
And the one that I'll talk
about for a few minutes
is the following one, and this is called
signaling by a morphogen gradient.
I talked about this in
some detail yesterday
but I'm going to just summarize
the main principles today.
And the idea is this: that
you have a part of an embryo
often named after Nieuwkoop or Spemann,
the people I mentioned early on,
where cells emit a signal,
and the signal they emit,
these little red spots that
you may just be able to see
around a cell called A
which is next to the source.
In a little bit longer, and
it's typically an hour or two,
more of these signal
molecules have been released
and they spread further
away from the source
so as to surround the
second cell in the row,
which now follows fate A, because it gets
the low concentration of them.
And later still, say, three hours later,
yet more of these
molecules have been formed
and they now reach the third
cell away from the source,
which again follows A.
Now, the cell that was near the source
first decides to become A,
and then it changes its mind
and decides to become B, and finally
it may change its mind and become C.
And the reason why this
process is so important
is that one signal coming from this center
can tell several cells
what they should become,
whether they become, say,
nerve or heart or gut
or anything, and the
position of those cells
is related to where the signal comes from.
So it's a very fundamental,
important process.
Now much of this work
happens to have been done
with amphibia, frogs, and it's interesting
to reflect for a moment
as to why it should be
or how it came about that
the frog commonly used
for this work is a South African frog.
And when you go back in
history, you find that
the first description
of this were incorrectly
called Bufo was in 1803
by a French museum worker
who never saw the animal
alive but he received
one through the post and
drew a picture of it.
And the interesting thing is that the only
really striking feature of this animal,
which is called Xenopus
which means strange claws,
is that it should have claws on the feet,
which he failed to observe.
You'd have thought if
you're given a dead frog
and there's nothing much to look at except
the fact that it has claws on the feet
you might actually have noticed
it, but he didn't do that.
And that's how it came into
existence, but a bit later
people wanted to grow
this animal like you do
for laboratory animals,
and someone, as it happens,
in Britain then collected some animals
and tried to grow them.
Now, they're tropical animals, and he had
a publication, the result
of which was to show
that if you have a
Bunsen burner underneath
a beaker with water,
you can keep the animals
inside that container.
It's an unbelievably crude
way of keeping animals warm,
and I think any animal
inspector in Britain, at least,
would immediately
disallow such a procedure
but nevertheless, that's how Mr. Bles came
to add to his publications, by inventing
a not very sophisticated
procedure of keeping animals warm.
Over the years a number of
people have worked on this
and this is a picture
of a famous embryologist
called Johannes Holtfreter, who was one
of the students of Spemann.
Spemann was a very austere
person with a rigid personality
and Holtfreter was a
rather lively student who
was actually very famous
because he discovered
a way of preventing nearly all the embryos
that Spemann worked with from dying.
So Spemann's famous experiment
which got him a Nobel Prize
was to graft tissue from
one embryo to another.
Very elegant experiment but the fact is
that almost all the embryos died.
I think three out of 150 showed the effect
for which the Nobel Prize was awarded,
the other 147 having died.
The reason they died was
that they got infected.
Now, Holtfreter was
clever enough to think of
making a solution
actually out of chemicals
from the shelf so there
weren't bacteria in it,
but he had a lively personality and much
of his time was spent
painting in Indonesia,
which was his hobby.
That infuriated Spemann and
so he disliked Holtfreter
and all his work, but
nevertheless, that's who he was
and he was really very
fundamentally enabling
much of the experimental
embryology now done today
to actually take place.
Now using these sorts of
methods one can explore
how cells signal to each other, and one
of the crucial methods
now is to take an embryo,
separate all the cells in suspension,
add to them some of these
known growth factors,
and there's one that
happens to be called activin
for only 10 minutes, so
you influence the cells,
and then you wash off
all the excess factor
and put them together and grow them.
And that's turned out to
be a very informative way
of establishing how
cells respond to signals.
One of the remarkable things now is that
one particular molecule, a
member of the TGF-beta class,
can be used to treat these
embryo cells in suspension.
And rather surprisingly you
can make almost every cell
in the body just by
treating these embryo cells
for a few minutes with
different concentrations
of this factor.
So if you use a low
concentration, middle, high,
or very high, you send cells
in different directions,
various genes are turned on,
and you can see that you end up
with blood, muscle,
cartilage, or intestine.
And that's a very important point
that by taking very early, naive cells,
and they really are very early,
you can give them different
amounts of the same substance
and tell them to form
totally different structures
which are the main components of our body.
And this point will be
quite relevant when I talk
about the second part of
this process tomorrow.
But it does raise the
question of how it is
that a cell can perceive or interpret
these different concentrations of factor.
And the concentrations are extremely small
and only two- or threefold
changes in concentration
will make the difference
between, for example,
heart or intestine, or bone, or blood.
We can see this process
working in this example
where these are beads, biochemical beads,
treated with the factor,
and they cause genes
to be turned on in this group of cells,
and when you increase the concentration
this gene response is
further away from the source.
So the strength of this signal will decide
how far away this response occurs,
very much like dropping or
throwing a stone into a pond.
There's a ripple of gene
response among these cells
and if you do it even stronger, the ripple
reaches the edge, as it were, of the pond.
And the point of saying
this is that the same cells
will respond in completely different ways
to the same purified biochemical
factor, same molecule.
It gives us a lot of
opportunity for determining
the way embryo cells
will develop and making
the kind of cells we
might wish them to form.
One of the principles here
is that these determinants,
these factors shown as blue
spots, move away from the source
in the space in between cells.
They bind to the matrix
with very low affinity
and occasionally they find a receptor
here on the cells to which
they bind very tightly
and will inform cells of the
fate that they should follow.
Now this is again a
rather remarkable process
which I'm going to explain
in a little more detail
by the use of, hopefully, a video.
If you take these cells, and
this is just one sort of cell,
and you treat them by adding this factor,
this TGF-beta molecule called
activin, for only 10 minutes,
you find that the molecule
in the cell which signals
to the genes to tell it
what it is, called Smad2,
goes into the nucleus,
and that green patch
is the presence of these
molecules inside this cell.
Now you notice that, for
only a 10-minute treatment,
the green molecules move
in, and there they still are
inside this cell as much as
four or five hours later.
And it turns out that these
cells remember, curiously,
the small amount of treatment they've had,
and they will follow a
fate, whether it's heart
or liver, or whatever else it is,
simply according to the
strength of that signal
that they received for 10 minutes.
So enhancing a point I've just made,
you can take these single cells, give them
a very short treatment
of some known factor.
The factor actually is a
gene product now purified.
And that very short experience of only
a 10-minute treatment will tell the cells
what kind of fate they should follow.
And this is the process called memory.
And when you integrate this information
the way it seems to work is the following:
that these cells receive this
signal and they absorb it,
and they start responding
to gene A, B, or C
according to the strength.
They then will remain at
that level of response,
to what the level line
means, until finally
they won't receive the signal anymore.
They become noncompetent; they
just won't receive it anymore
and the signal goes down.
Now they have to remain
expressing a constant response
for some time to make
enough of the product
to guide the cells in the directions
they eventually need to go.
I'm now going to try and explain how it is
that this whole process works.
And there's one
fundamental principle here,
and that is that what really matters
is the concentration of this signal factor
inside the nucleus of the cell,
and it actually is the
volume of that material
which is passing within
the cell to the genes.
And I show these two pictures because they
illustrate the point that
the flow rate of something,
the rate of flow is not
relevant here at all;
it's the volume.
Now this rather splendid
picture of the Victoria
waterfalls coming from there,
there's a substantial distance
that the water is falling,
and of course the rate
at which that water falls
will be more or less
proportional to the height.
There's a certain rate of
flow, but in this case,
the source is very small.
There's a little stream
there, and it will follow down
and the volume, though
it looks considerable
from this picture, is
actually quite limited.
Now if we compare that
waterfall to another one
equally famous that you may have seen
called the Iguazú Falls
on the border of Paraguay
and Uruguay and, I think, Brazil,
the distance is the same,
the height is the same,
but the volume of water
is absolutely immense.
It kind of falls right
across that whole hillside
and indeed 'round the corner.
And it is the volume of flow that makes
the difference in cells.
And, indeed, these two
examples, which show
the cells follow a
completely different fate
according to the volume of flow,
not the rate of flow or anything else.
Now I have a video which
explains this clearly,
if the video shows, and it's going
to work the following way:
We have outside the
cell these green objects
which are the signal
factors coming from a source
and you'll see them coming from this side
and moving across, and as they move,
they have some chance of some
of them finding a receptor.
This is what they have to find.
When they do find that,
the red signal molecule,
the one that was shown
as bright green before,
goes into the nucleus where
it forms a concentration
which is sufficient to turn
on the appropriate gene,
in this case, A.
In order to keep this working smoothly,
something or other has
to come along and remove
all those molecules from outside the cell.
There is a point in
showing these butterflies,
which you may wonder
why they're being shown.
And the point of doing
so is that this concept
of a morphogen gradient concentration,
and this actually applies fairly widely.
Now you may be able to
see perhaps that these
rather splendid undersides of butterflies
have these brilliant ring
spots with many ripples
of colors in this particular species.
And the Femme Fatale is
a great expert on this
but it seems almost certainly
that this coloration
in butterflies, fish, birds, works
by a morphogen gradient
process by which cells
sense a wave of molecules going past them
and switch on genes accordingly.
And I draw this one because to me this is
a really interesting
problem in the future.
One is to understand how could these
complicated patterns arise with a source?
But another butterfly,
this one, has the top side
completely black, and the other side
of the same butterfly has
this almost straight line
straight down the middle.
And to me it's almost inexplicable how
a mechanism that can produce
ripples of concentration there
can produce an almost ruled straight line
down the other side.
It must have something
to do with the diffusion
of molecules, but
curiously it's a completely
non-understood phenomenon.
So the last few minutes,
what I'll talk about now
is the remaining point, and this is
the so-called community effect.
And the principle of this
idea is the following:
that we've talked about
cells that receive signals
as they come from one direction.
But it turns out that another
mechanism of signaling
is one where cells
receive an initial signal
of one kind to get them
going at a low level.
And then what they do is
to signal to themselves
and enhance the response, so it's as if
various of you received some indication
that there was something happening
and then once you've got that signal
you all had to put your hands up and show
your neighbors that you've got the signal
and that constitutes a
message to all your neighbors
that they must now respond
in a particular way.
So the idea is this:
that these two pink cells
have received a signal,
and they've just started
following the muscle
pathway, like hard muscle,
but they're only pink
because the concentration
of black spots is very low.
Now if all of these cells
in a group were to emit
the same black spots, but
they're next to each other,
the concentration of those black spots
is now enormously higher simply because
they are next to each
other and they build up
this concentration, and when that happens,
the whole group collectively
will then switch
and progress to another
kind of differentiation;
in this particular case it's muscle.
Now in this case you
really can't see anything.
And I can see quite well on
the screen but you can't.
There are single cells which
are essentially invisible
and they are sitting alone
without any neighbors.
And when you look at that
there is no response.
Had there been a response
there'd be black spots
showing a gene response.
Now when you have a lot
of these cells together
and here is about 100 of them in a group,
they're all marked with
a lineage marker, red,
and when you look for the
response, here are the black spots
so all of those cells
have turned on a gene,
the muscle gene, only
because they were present
in this large community together.
So that is the concept
of a community effect,
and it does matter, so
that when they signal
to each other you get
something like a 10-fold
increase in the response.
Now I'll now show another picture,
and this is a fiendish fish,
you may be able to see,
which lives in the deep water, and it has
a light organ, here, it
has this sort of projection
which is very brightly colored.
In fact, it emits light.
And what happens is that
the light attracts prey
which this fiendish
animal then gobbles up.
Now, what is the relevance?
It turns out that this process has a name
called quorum sensing;
it means that the quorum,
enough of them working
together produce a result.
And the explanation for
this is the following:
that in that light
organ, there are bacteria
and they live there, and the bacteria
cause the turning on of a gene
that emits light, Lux gene.
The interesting thing
is, for that to happen,
you need to have an
exceptionally high concentration
of these bacteria, something like
a thousand million per mil.
Whereas when there's a
much lower concentration,
a few hundred per mil,
that is insufficient
to activate the bacteria
to turn on the gene.
And they even know the
name of the chemical,
which is called homoserine lactone.
And the principle here
is that the concentration
of bacteria in that space
signal to each other
to then cause the turning on of this gene,
which only happens when
there are enough of them
actually working together, so what we call
the community effect in
development and creating
cells like, organs like
the heart and muscle
depends on this community effect.
And unknown to me at the
time when we worked that out,
the bacteriologist had
worked out this process
of the homoserine lactone
working for quorum sensing.
So the concept here is a
fairly general one in science
and it makes the point that
for cells to actually follow
a particular fate, you
need the combination
of the two processes.
So here is a diagram to
indicate that if you have.
I can barely read it at the top,
you have a concentration of this factor
which I've been talking
about called activin
ranging from about three
to 10 to 30 picoMolar,
different three times-fold concentrations,
only threefold changes.
At this concentration followed
by the community effect
all of those cells now
switch on a gene called MyoD
and that's shown as a black spot.
And likewise they'll
turn on cardiac actin,
the muscle actin at that concentration.
But if you start them off at
a higher concentration here
only threefold different,
then when they communicate
with each other, they will then turn on
the gut gene, the endodermin gene.
So it means that the principle is that
it's the combination of
a signal from some source
going through like a morphogen action
and then being amplified by the cells
that receive that signal,
then signaling again
to themselves to enhance
the original effect.
And you end up in this way with organs
like we have the heart and so on.
But it does depend on this
sequential kind of signaling.
So now let me first summarize
what I've said at some length.
And then finally I'll
give you a bottom line.
So I'm going to have to read this
'cause that light's in the way.
What it says is, reading from the top:
An embryo is usually formed
by a maternally created
first axis, the mother
fixes that, followed
by an environmentally induced second axis
such as sperm entry.
And the second point is that
cells, tissues, and organs
are formed by a combination
of first, the asymmetric
distribution of determinants
at cell division,
and secondly, by signals from other cells.
The morphogen gradient interpretation
is an important mechanism for activating
gene expression in the correct position.
And lastly, the community effect converts
gene expression into final cell types.
Now you'll probably say
or people may say to you,
what did the man say in
this 45 minutes of lecture,
and they always expect a bottom line.
So I'm giving you a bottom
line in case you have
no idea what I've talked about at all.
And so what this, this is ...
(audience laughs)
... a bottom line.
It's a Biblical statement
you may recognize.
It says, Faith, hope, and charity,
and the greatest of these is charity.
Now, the embryologist
would say, Space, time,
and concentration, and
the greatest of these
is concentration.
So the bottom line is concentration.
(audience laughs)
And finally, let me
just say that the people
whose work I've referred
to, colleagues Steven Dyson,
Pierre-Yves Bourillot, Jerome Jullien,
and I've been kindly given
videos by my colleagues
Andrea Brand and Magdalena Zernicka-Goetz,
and we're supported by the Wellcome Trust.
Thank you.
(applause)
- [Man With Snail Question]
You had the snails up there,
and you had those four
rows, or four levels.
The second-to-last level
was all sinistral, dextral,
I don't remember which,
and then the last one,
it was made up of recessive-recessive,
recessive-dominant, dominant-recessive,
and dominant-dominant,
they had the direction.
But you explained that
all the way down but
if you explained it, I didn't get it.
The last line there, when
they're heterogeneous,
but they're mixed with
the big Ds and the small.
The last line on that slide,
are you following this?
- I think I can; let me try
to contribute to your point.
It did look a rather
forbiddingly complicated picture
but the basic principle
was this: that the genetic
constitution of the mother,
which is variably described
as little dd or big
D-little d, or big D-big D,
determines the dextrality,
D stands for dextrality,
so the principle is that if
it's a capital D-capital D,
that's for dextral.
It's a dominant gene, so
if it's big D-little d,
that also means dextral.
Only if it's a little d-little
d, the double recessive,
does that make it sinistral.
And the point of the diagram was that
the only thing that actually
decides the coiling,
or the shell pattern of the offspring,
is the genetic constitution of the mother,
not the genetic constitution
of the snail itself.
That was the complication,
because normally
we think that if we have
genes of a certain kind,
that will determine what
we are, and that is,
indeed, the normal situation.
But it was very confusing,
the time that this
absolutely didn't apply;
it only depended on
the genetic constitution of the mother,
not of the mother and
father as it would with us.
And I might add that the case
was even more complicated
because they chose to do
experiments with snails
which have the extraordinary disadvantage
of being prepared, one snail would mate
with another snail but, amazingly enough,
the snail will self-fertilize itself,
so it mates with itself
when it feels like it.
So that is
(audience laughs)
quite extraordinarily confusing.
- [Man With Snail Question]
Hermaphroditic, yeah.
- If you were designing this experiment
you would never, ever start with snails
that can self-fertilize
or cross-fertilize,
and indeed, no one's ever done experiments
with snails again as far as I know
(audience laughs)
and for a very good reason.
So if you imagine it,
and you didn't understand
anything about maternal inheritance,
it's really quite amazing
that this was worked out.
So the basic principle is
that once you understand
that the only thing that matters here
is the genetic constitution
of your mother,
and your father's completely irrelevant,
then the whole thing makes sense.
- [Man With Snail Question]
But didn't your last line
have them all in the same direction?
- Yeah, they were all right-handed.
- [Man With Snail Question]
But it was the opposite
of the previous line,
the opposite of the line
of mother, of all that generation.
- They were all dextral, right-handed.
- [Man With Snail Question]
And the ones above
were all sinistral?
- The dextrals all came from a mother
which was, herself, sinistral, but had the
genetic constitution of being right-handed
so she became sinistral because her mother
had that constitution,
and she as a daughter
then got a right-handed
constitution to ensure
that all her progeny
were right-handed snails.
- [Man With Snail Question]
It's constitutional ...
- I didn't invent the way snails work,
but that's how it is, actually.
(applause)
(perky synth music)